a final farewell from those who loved
her most
debra james's children walked in silence
behind their mother's coffin side by
side with their father
at the church her teenage son hugo
helped carry her wicker casket
a few weeks on from her death six years
on from her diagnosis of bowel cancer in
her community people paid their respects
as she passed
but deborah in in
the style that we've all become a
costume accustomed to was
was very um
very brave and how she handled it and
you know
she was just very brave and very
positive what an amazing person and she
would be sorely missed in our community
and that was a real special moment
very kind of sad and i was pleased i was
there to witness it
debra james danced through her cancer
treatment posting open and unsparing
messages with humor and candor
[Music]
she raised millions for charity in her
final months honoured with a damehood by
the duke of cambridge a testament to the
love and admiration she inspired
she made a subject that is
painful
deeply embarrassing
um
acceptable to talk about she was so
candid and so down to earth and i'm sure
that the figures have changed
for the better in terms of symptom
awareness and the red flag symptoms of
bowel cancer dame deborah james
undoubtedly saved countless lives one
tribute said she taught us how to live
and how to die
enjoy life because it is so precious
it's
all i want right now is more time and
more life
and
i would also check your poo
the tireless campaigner finally at rest
adele robinson sky news barnes